HOFFMAN: Foreigners coming to America to kill
Americans - we immediately condemn it, and
we see it as offensive, wrong, illegal, and
we've waged a 20-year war on terrorism against
this kind of threat.
Somehow when it occurs in the United States,
it's something we ignore, we don't want to
come to grips with.
And in part, that's because of constitutional
freedoms, freedom of expression, freedom of
assembly.
But we have to understand that words matter.
And that words can be weaponized, that as
we've seen, unfortunately, in the digital
era, be very quickly and easily transformed
into wanton outright violence
SIERRA: Last month, on a bright day in the
Capitol, President Biden used a phrase that
no previous president had used in an inaugural
address.
White supremacy.
President Joe Biden: A rise in political extremism,
white supremacy, domestic terrorism.
SIERRA: His words were delivered in the very
spot where just one week earlier a mob of
insurrectionists stormed the Capitol at the
behest of President Donald Trump.
The riot was not exclusively a white supremacist
event, but it did bring together extremists
from a wide array of white nationalist and
white supremacist groups - many openly carrying
flags and symbols in support of their movements.
One of the most haunting images of that day
was that of the confederate flag being lofted
in the halls of the Capitol building.
For years, the United States has devoted enormous
resources to fighting transnational terrorism,
but until now, the threat of homegrown, white
supremacist terror has not received the same
focus.
Even after multiple mass shootings, even as
the FBI and the Department of Homeland Security
designated it as the most lethal domestic
threat.
But now, that seems to be changing.
I'm Gabrielle Sierra, and this is Why It Matters.
Today, white nationalism, white supremacy,
and the fight to come.
The New Yorker: "USA, USA…"
CBS NEWS: The situation has reached a dire
point where the U.S Capitol is now in lockdown,
both the House and Senate.
CBS NEWS: We are learning more about the Capitol
police officer who died of the injuries from
the attack.
42-year-old Brian Sicknick served his country
in Iraq.
Arnold Schwarzenegger: I grew up in Austria.
I'm very aware of Kristallnacht, or the Night
of Broken Glass.
It was a night of rampage against the Jews
carried out in 1938 by the Nazi equivalent
of the Proud Boys.
Wednesday was the Day of Broken Glass right
here in the United States.
SIERRA: So, to start with, I think it's important
to have a definition.
What is white nationalism?
HOFFMAN: White nationalism, I would define,
is an overarching concept that embraces the
idea of white supremacism.
SIERRA: This is Bruce Hoffman.
He's a Senior Fellow for counterterrorism
and homeland security at the Council on Foreign
Relations and a leading expert on terrorism.
In 2014 he was appointed by Congress to lead
a review of the FBI's response to 9/11.
HOFFMAN: It embraces a very strident xenophobic
or anti-immigrant position.
It is hostile to all those who are deemed,
quote-unquote, "the other."
In other words, all these strangers, all these
new immigrants, are taking what is "ours,"
but not just "ours" in any kind of material
sense.
"Ours" indeed is a birthright.
The goal of a white nationalist, I would argue,
is to rally as many people of his or her race
into not just accepting but emulating and
adopting their own exclusionary, discriminatory
xenophobic views.
SIERRA: The topic of white nationalism and
white supremacist extremism is complex.
And it lies in the shadow of the far larger
problem of racism itself.
As you might expect with such a complicated
issue, there is debate about nomenclature.
MILLER-IDRISS: I'm going to use the term white
supremacist extremism and then tell you why
I think it's better than white nationalism.
SIERRA: This is Cynthia Miller-Idris, a sociologist
at American University in the School of Public
Affairs and the director of the Polarization
and Extremism Research and Innovation Lab,
or PERIL.
MILLER-IDRISS: So white supremacist extremism
is an ideology that believes in a hierarchy
of superiority and inferiority, that is racial,
that it puts white people, "white civilizations,"
as they often use the term, above all others.
It's a global ideology.
And that global ideology rests on a conspiracy
theory that is called the Great Replacement
that believes that white civilizations are
being deliberately eradicated through demographic
change and immigration at the hands of usually
Jews and Muslims.
Vox: America was built by and for the white
Christian people in this nation.
CNN: We're staring down the barrel of a gun
here in white America.
We have the possibility of becoming a minority
in our own country...a possibility.
EURONEWS: I say immigrants, I'm actually using
the wrong word.
They are actually conquerors, and that's the
thing that we need to understand.
Most white people are handing them the keys
to our country.
MILLER-IDRISS: White supremacist extremists,
they have specific policy proposals in mind,
but essentially, they want to restore a white
civilization.
They want to deport or what they sometimes
call in softer language re-migrate people
who are non-white back to their countries
of origin.
So white nationalism, which some people use,
has two problems.
One is that it can sometimes have the effect
of softening what is really extremist, and
sometimes even terrorist behavior and making
it sound like it's just overblown patriotism.
And it also sort of has the effect of making
it seem like it's a national problem when
I think it is clearly a global problem.
SIERRA: If you have spent any time on the
internet or listening to the news or podcasts
about this problem, you will know that there
are lots of groups.
So, there are dozens of militias, neo-Nazi
organizations, and groups with a specific
emphasis on hate.
There are the Oath Keepers and the Three Percenters,
and the Proud Boys, the self-defined "western
chauvinists," who gained some fame after President
Trump told them to "stand back and stand by."
And then, there are other groups that overlap
into this far-right extremist space.
There's QAnon, a conspiracy theory that features
Satan-worshipping pedophiles controlling our
government.
There are concepts like the "boogaloo," a
coded reference to a second civil war, and
"incels," a rallying idea for men with deeply
misogynistic and violent views.
The deeper you dig, the more terms and movements
you uncover.
SIERRA: Do you think that one problem with
assessing all this is just the sheer number
of groups?
To what degree are these groups all part of
the same movement?
And what makes it so difficult to pin this
down?
HOFFMAN: It's very hard to get a handle on
how many individuals are involved in these
types of movements because a lot of it is
done anonymously.
And that's one of the benefits of social media,
the internet, is you can be completely anonymous;
you could have avatars or monikers that don't
reveal your true identity.
But there's another element to this is that
we're not talking about organizations, we're
talking about networks, and networks that
often have overlapping memberships.
I mean, we may like to create our boxes of
the Three Percenters or the Oath Keepers,
or the Proud Boys, or the QAnon, and so on,
what we fail to realize that you don't get
a membership card.
SIERRA: There may not be membership cards,
but there is a basic idea shared across all
white nationalist groups.
And that's the idea that white Americans are
the only legitimate Americans.
Problems, whether personal, national, or imagined,
are blamed on non-white Americans.
MILLER-IDRISS: So the way I think of it, it's
a spectrum of far-right groups that share
both anti-democratic ideals, beliefs, and
practices, hierarchies of beliefs about superiority
and inferiority, and a willingness to use
violence, to enact their political goals.
Combined with people who are called accelerationist,
or have fantasies about a collapse of society,
the desire to bring about a civil war, or
an insurrection or chaos for the sake of chaos,
so that there'll be a collapse and apocalyptic
kind of end times, and then rebirth into a
new civilization.
HOFFMAN: And the trouble is because their
agendas are so overlapping in many respects,
people subscribe to a variety of them.
So we're talking about something that is much
more amorphous and much more diffuse than
we've ever seen in the past.
And, of course, this challenges the very foundation
of how we've always understood counterterrorism
by focusing on the organizations.
This is why the U.S. State Department, for
instance, has a foreign terrorist organization
designation.
Because you can identify the organization,
you can identify the leader, and you can get
a sense of how many members, and then you
can sanction it.
We're talking about something that is much
more difficult to tangibly understand.
And therefore, this has worked to their advantage
and also slowed our efforts not just to understand
but to legislate against it.
MILLER-IDRISS: There's definitely not a unified
movement, even though they have tried to.
So, in the U.S., the most obvious moment when
they deliberately tried to unify the movement
was in Charlottesville in 2017, when they
held a rally that a lot of people have forgotten,
that was actually called Unite the Right.
CNN: Jews will not replace us.
Jews will not replace us.
CBS: Today's Unite the Right rally, which
is expected to draw thousands of white nationalists,
neo-
Nazis.
CNN: They carry torches a nod to the torches
like Nazi rallies of Adolph Hitler.
They chanted, 'Jews will not replace us.'
ABC News: It was a weekend of street battles
and stark displays of racism.
Tonight, we examine the hateful groups that
now appear to be banding together.
MILLER-IDRISS: That was the whole intent of
that rally was to try to bring together what
had been a far-right spectrum that was infighting,
that was at odds with each other, that was
deeply fragmented, and try to unite them all,
under one banner and see if they could be
a stronger force in American society and in
American politics.
That failed.
They fragmented just as badly, if not worse
afterward.
But I think what we then saw was three and
a half years of the mainstreaming and normalization
of right-wing, far-right, whatever you want
to call it, and then they unified around this
sort of disinformation landscape around the
election.
And so what we saw then, in the US, January
6, was a real uniting of the right, unfortunately,
a broad spectrum of far-right groups that
came together to enact violence.
So really, those goals that these groups had
forged back in 2017 really did come to fruition
in 2021.
SIERRA: As experts analyzed evidence from
the Capitol attack, they found that members
of more than a dozen of these groups had participated,
including Qanon adherents, militia members,
Proud Boys, and white supremacist organizations.
The spectacle of these different groups, uniting
around an attempt to overturn an election,
shocked many across the country.
But the problem has been centuries in the
making.
HOFFMAN: It goes way back, of course.
One could argue that it goes back to even
before the founding of the Republic, of course,
when slavery was introduced to the United
States in 1619.
One can trace it certainly, to the Know Nothing
movements that arose in the United States
at the beginning of the 19th century, which
sought to target, in particular, Irish Catholic
immigrants to the urban centers of the Northeast.
It certainly emerged in the period of reconstruction
with the emergence of the Ku Klux Klan.
It gathered new momentum in the 1920s, especially
when very stringent and strict immigration
laws were passed precisely to keep immigrants
from eastern and southern Europe from coming
to the United States who were seen as not
just polluting the United States and poisoning
its white Anglo-Saxon Christian purity, but
I think significantly for 2021, were seen
as bringing disease and plagues with them.
And of course, we've seen, then, it resurface
in the 1950s, in the 1960s.
But I would say the launch point for what
we see in the 21st century really occurred
in the late 1970s - early 1980s, when you
had, I think, a remarkably similar constellation
of events.
You had, firstly, many Americans who were
tired of a prolonged overseas military expedition
and engagement in a far-off land that was
in Vietnam and the U.S. wars in Indochina.
That because of the prolongation of those
wars, and what they saw was the defeat where
the United States, after the considerable
sacrifice of blood and treasure, just picked
up and left this profound disillusionment
with elected leadership.
It was a time also coming off of profound
economic instability and very high inflation
rates that created fears of jobs disappearing
overseas, for example, of really the diminishment
of blue-collar employment opportunities in
the United States and the emergence of the
Rust Belt as it were.
And all those factors combined to give rise
to what was the first attempts to really integrate
and coordinate and provide an organizational
superstructure to the various strands of white
nationalism, white supremacism, racism, extreme
anti-government sentiment, belief in no veracity
or no power of the government above the county
level, anti-semitism and so on.
And we see many stark parallels today to that
previous era.
SIERRA: The period of the 1970s and 80s may
not be the most notorious moment in the history
of American racial terror.
But Bruce points it out, not only because
of the stark parallels to our own time but
also because innovations among white supremacists
then sowed the seeds of the problem as it
exists now.
HOFFMAN: The advent of lone wolves or lone
actor terrorism, and also online radicalization
and recruitment, both have their roots in
1983 and 1984, when American white supremacists
championed a strategy of what they called
leaderless resistance or "autonomous phantom
cell units."
In other words, the FBI in that era was so
successful in penetrating and undermining,
and neutralizing these groups that the white
supremacists and white nationalists of that
era decided we need a new strategy.
SIERRA: By decentralizing, these groups made
it much harder for law enforcement to track,
infiltrate, and break them up.
By forgoing hierarchy and instead relying
on individual actors, a threat could emerge
from anywhere at any time.
HOFFMAN: The second innovation is that at
the time, the white supremacists in the United
States were deliberately trying to forge international
links, particularly with their like-minded
hatemongers in Canada and what was then West
Germany.
The problem was, every time they sent their
hate literature through the U.S. mail, that
became a federal offense, and they were vulnerable
to being arrested for sending hate mail through
the U.S. Postal Service.
So that's why, in fact, the same individual
Louis Beam, who came up, or adopted, or popularized
the notion of leaderless resistance, in 1984,
came up with the idea of using at the time
state of the art technology, now very primitive
communications technologies; basically, modems
that operated 48 to 84 baud.
I mean, this is like, infinitesimally slower
than anything we have today.
Using computers that back then cost around
three or four thousand dollars in today's
money that had 48,000 memory.
But nonetheless, using these modems and these
bulletin boards, they were able to obviate
US Postal regulations that would have put
them in jail, but even more importantly, frustrate
the efforts of the FBI and the authorities
to monitor them, to surveil them, because
of course, technologically, the U.S. government
was far less sophisticated than the private
sector.
And what we see today is that something they
could never have dreamt of in the 1980s, the
power of social media platforms, where you
have thousands, tens of thousands, hundreds
of thousands potential friends, associates,
individuals in your circle or network that
you can reach instantaneously at very low
cost.
And, of course, radicalize, inspire, motivate
and animate them to commit acts of violence.
MILLER-IDRISS: I mean, this isn't created
by social media.
It isn't created by the ability of these online
ecosystems, but they are underpinning it and
helping its growth and helping people use
these events as a channel for recruitment
for radicalization and further mobilization.
There is still a really important component
to it, the real-life kinds of gatherings.
It's important that this was symbolically
at the Capitol, right?
But it was also live-streamed.
There was live chatter on chat fora.
There were many different ways that the performance
of it also relied on this online ecosystem
as well as all the planning that goes on prior
to something like this happening, relying
on encrypted apps and chat rooms, and sometimes
very public social media posts that made threats.
SIERRA: Social media plays a key role at every
stage.
It has created an unprecedented level of disinformation
and polarization the world over - and this
atmosphere is key for recruitment to extremist
ideologies.
It then facilitates bonds between extremists
despite geographical distance, allowing them
to talk, refine their hate, and articulate
their goals.
In the lead-up to an attack, and even during,
it helps them plan and coordinate.
Finally, it allows them to broadcast the attack
live, furthering their recruitment and accelerationist
goals.
The Capital was not the first live-streamed
white extremist attack.
In fact, by January 6, the technique had been
refined for years.
One of the most infamous examples happened
in 2019 in Christchurch, New Zealand.
CBS NEWS: A racist, terror attack in New Zealand,
targeting two mosques, leaving this morning
at least 49 people dead, and many more wounded.
ABC NEWS: The man who was claiming responsibility
and charged with murder is an extreme right-wing
white supremacist who live-streamed the attack,
saying it was aimed at immigrants.
CAN: Many of those who will have been directly
affected by the shooting may be migrants to
New Zealand.
They may even be refugees here.
They have chosen to make New Zealand their
home, and it is their home.
They are us.
MILLER-IDRISS: What happened in Christchurch
was shocking on a lot of levels.
It was an attack on two mosques.
People who were peacefully worshiping really
were massacred, you know, gunned down.
It was live-streamed, and so it began a new
moment in the kind of use of the Internet
to turn terrorism and to what already had
been for a long time, which is bloody political
theater, and really bring it to a global stage.
And then, you know, even though Facebook and
others really tried to pretty quickly take
down that live stream, it had been downloaded
so many times.
It was very difficult to get that off.
There was, you know, music.
There was a playlist, right?
It was very much appealing to youth who came
of age kind of, in a very technically highly
developed online gaming world, where, because
of the use of the GoPro kind of camera that
allowed for that live streaming to feel more
like an attack in an online game.
And so that kind of created a whole new way
of communicating terrorist events that I think
we've seen ever since in terms of using the
live streaming capabilities to try to broadcast
immediately what was happening and further
terrorize the public in a whole different
way.
SIERRA: As shocking as Christchurch was, by
2019, mass-casualty attacks by white extremists
had become gruesomely common.
In 2011 a devastating attack in Norway claimed
77 lives and included a manifesto from the
perpetrator that was enshrined by white supremacists
across the world in the years that followed.
A 2015 attack on a black church in Charleston,
South Carolina, claimed nine lives.
In 2018, an attack on the Tree of Life synagogue
in Pittsburgh claimed 11.
The list goes on, and on, and on.
As the pattern unfolded, experts began to
warn that domestic terror was emerging as
a more serious threat than transnational terror
and that U.S. resources long engaged in fighting
terrorism abroad should be allocated accordingly.
By 2020, the Department of Homeland Security
had designated violent white supremacy as
the "most persistent and lethal threat in
the homeland."
The change was slow to come.
SIERRA: So, earlier, you know, you mentioned
Al-Qaeda and ISIS.
So in my lifetime, the word terrorism has
been very strongly associated with Islamic
extremism.
So do you think you can tell us a little bit
more about the relationship between those
movements and white nationalist terrorism?
HOFFMAN: The parallels between ISIS and the
white supremacists are enormous.
They're both talking about a halcyon period
in the past of historical greatness that they're
intent on restoring, and they talk about interlopers,
foreigners, outsiders who are impinging upon
their customs, their beliefs, their societal
values that need to be countered.
They're clustering very much inward in an
almost a
Manichaean "us against them" kind of mentality.
No, there are, unfortunately, a lot of parallels.
What I think worries me the most is that there's
a circularity or a feedback loop in that Al-Qaeda
and ISIS, whether consciously or otherwise,
I would argue, learn from the experience of
American white supremacist, as I've described
with this concept of lone wolves that harkens
back to leaderless resistance, which was the
white supremacist term, and the use of radicalization,
and recruitment using computers, and now subsequently
digital means and social media.
So I say they learned from the white supremacists.
But what we're seeing now is the white supremacists
also learning very much in particular, from
ISIS, and using many of the same tactics,
techniques, and means of radicalization and
recruitment, that we see ISIS having used
to become so effective in such a short span
of time.
SIERRA: The basic goals of ISIS and American
white extremists are similar: they both want
to drive out the "other" and restore an imaginary
time in which they alone wielded power.
And these basic motivations are common to
ethnic and nationalist terror all over the
world.
In almost every country in Europe, whether
France, Germany, Poland, or Hungary, there
are extremist groups, and even political parties,
working to push out the "other" and restore
an imaginary past.
SIERRA: Do you think that the U.S. national
security apparatus is well-positioned to address
this threat?
HOFFMAN: Well, the authorities in the United
States are well-positioned to respond to the
threat.
We have enormously effective law enforcement
and intelligence agencies that, when given
their orders, when given prioritization, directives
from the top, are very effective.
There's no doubt they've kept us safe for
decades.
The problem I see is less the agencies and
more the political will.
And also the national support behind that
political will.
So there has to be some sort of reckoning,
really, and a deeper discussion that addresses
the context in the background of how we've
gotten to where we are today, if we're ever
to make meaningful progress in preventing
the types of outrageous activities that we
saw in the United States Capitol on January
6.
I mean, protests that desecrate, that vandalize,
that smear blood and feces on the bastion
of United States democracy, on probably one
of the most hallowed institutions and buildings
in this country, I think, indicate that something
has gone wrong somewhere.
MILLER-IDRISS: I think that the FBI has the
expertise and could shift the resources and
has been trying to shift the resources.
The director of the FBI has testified several
times now before Congress about the dilemmas
they have faced with the imbalance and resources,
what they are supposed to be dedicating their
time toward, in terms of Islamist terrorism
and international terrorism versus domestic
extremism and terrorism.
I think there are a number of other problems,
though, on the law enforcement side, one of
which is that there is both kind of unconscious
bias and racism that we know is present and
we have seen throughout the Black Lives Matter
protest is a reaction to police brutality
that clearly plays a role in the lack of preparatory
response to the January 6 attacks in terms
of who's deemed a threat and how prepared
they were in riot gear.
We have anecdote after anecdote of law enforcement
officers, including some who were present
now, as we're finding out in those attacks
on the Capitol, they're caught for being members
of white supremacist extremists or other far-right
groups and militias.
And so you have groups that are deliberately
trying to recruit from law enforcement.
On the militia side, you have incident after
incident of officers, border control officers,
nearly 10,000 of them being caught in a racist
Facebook group, you know, sharing racist,
kind of, information and chats.
But what we don't have is data.
And so we don't actually know is this a few
bad apples?
Or is it a systematic problem?
There's anecdote after anecdote, and after
a while, so many anecdotes add up to at least
there should be data available, mandated reporting
from the Department of Defense and the Department
of Justice.
SIERRA: Many people don't realize it, but
there is no federal law addressing domestic
terror.
Some say this needs to change if the FBI is
going to execute its mission effectively.
President Biden signaled his support for such
a law in the wake of the Capitol riots and
has ordered the office of the director of
national intelligence to review the domestic
terror threat with an eye on future policy.
Another proposal will allow the FBI to formally
designate domestic terror organizations for
the first time.
MILLER-IDRISS: We do need new legislation.
But I'm also cautious, and I understand the
concerns of civil rights groups about the
calls for a federal domestic terrorism statute.
For example, how can we collect and share
the data?
What's the scope?
And how do you address it?
And I understand that it's extremely frustrating
for law enforcement to have to charge people
on things like weapons charges or something
when actually, it's clear that they were plotting,
you know, if they don't have the right tools
to charge people with what they're doing.
But I will say that I think there's a lot
of concern from civil rights groups about
the violations against Muslim communities
that happened in the post-911 era.
I think the answer to an injustice like that
is not to repeat the same injustice with other
citizens to make it equal but to really try
to learn from those mistakes and think how
we can do better than repeating those same
mistakes?
HOFFMAN: I think we need new laws that come
to grips more effectively with domestic terrorism.
Now, senior Department of Justice officials
and those in the FBI, I think, make the entirely
legitimate and germane and even cogent point
that the existing laws are enough.
Criminal homicide, vandalism, bombing, arson,
I mean, these are all criminal offenses; we
don't need additional statutes.
However, you could make the same point about
hate crimes, which embrace all of those things.
And we do have separate criminal statutes
for hate crimes that often impose penalties
in some instances, three or four times greater
than normal, criminal sentences or sanctions.
Because as a society, we want to single out
hate crimes as being particularly important
to a country whose motto is "E Pluribus Unum"––"from
many, one," that is talking about the diversity
of the United States.
And in that sense, we do need some domestic
terrorism legislation, if only because it
would close the disparity that we see in the
sentencing, for instance, of persons implicated
in support of foreign, or commission of violent
acts on behalf of foreign terrorists, and
those domestic.
SIERRA: And as the U.S. debates whether it
needs new laws to prosecute domestic terrorists,
there is a more difficult debate afoot about
how to reign in social media's enormous power
to amplify hate and aid in the commission
of terrorist acts.
A problem that butts up against the United
States' robust free speech protections.
HOFFMAN: I think what's clear is that the
law hasn't kept pace with technology.
We're only very belatedly in the aftermath
of the Christchurch massacres, we started
to talk about it, but those discussions in
many countries hadn't gone very far.
Now we're presented with the events of January
6, 2021, at the United States Capitol where
clearly social media played an enormous part,
and even if the mainstream Big Tech companies
like Facebook or Twitter, for example, removing
this kind of content, it didn't disappear.
It just migrated to entirely unregulated sites,
especially like Telegram, for example, but
also to sites like Parler, and Gab, and elsewhere.
So we really haven't started that discussion.
The Federal Communications Act section 230,
for instance, excludes social media from many
of the same restrictions that apply to mainstream
media, to television stations to newspapers
to radio outlets.
In an era where most people are getting their
news from social media and not from these
traditional mainstream sources, one has to
ask whether that's still logical.
I'm not a jurist.
I don't have the answer, but we really haven't
had the debate.
This is a long-overdue discussion and debate
that, of course, is going to receive far greater
priority in the coming months, and one has
to say years.
I mean, what we're seeing in the United States
today is not a flash in the pan; emerging
from this is going to take many years, if
not a decade.
And of course, this is going to prompt greater
introspection, and I think much more fulsome
discussion and legislation.
SIERRA: Looking ahead, these movements may
only seem to be gaining steam, amassing more
followers who feel emboldened to act on their
hateful ideologies.
And honestly, as a woman, as a Jewish Puertorican,
as a human being living in this world, it
is not only unsettling but straight-up terrifying.
But we have one advantage - the threat has
been laid bare.
For any skeptics who remained after Charleston,
after the Tree of Life, after Christchurch,
the image of nationalists storming the Capitol
has put the debate to rest.
Achieving consensus on this threat is an important
milestone.
But for a subset of Americans, the Capitol
attack only reinforced a lack of trust in
government.
And this mentality continues to be fanned
not only by the networks of online hate but
also by some mainstream media outlets and
political supporters of former President Donald
Trump, and even by members of the current
U.S. Congress who go to work every day in
the building where it happened.
The road is not going to be smooth.
The threat is real, and we can never allow
ourselves to return to the time in which we
ignored it or quibbled about its nature.
Understanding and teaching the history of
our country's relationship to white supremacy,
and its long history of racial terror, is
essential to maintaining this clarity.
As is teaching the history of the foundational
role that immigration and cultural diversity
play in our country's strength.
In the past, the United States has demonstrated
its resolve to unite against foreign threats.
We will now see if it can do so against a
threat to our safety, and our deepest values,
from within.
For resources used in this episode and more
information, visit CFR.org/Whyitmatters and
take a look at the show notes.
Have a question or some feedback?
Just feel like saying hey?
Send us an email at whyitmatters@cfr.org.
Subscribe to the show on Apple Podcasts, Spotify,
Stitcher, or wherever you get your audio.
And, please please, if you are a fan of the
show, show us some love!
Give us five stars and leave a review on Apple
Podcasts.
It means so much to us, and it really does
help us to get noticed.
Why It Matters is a production of the Council
on Foreign Relations.
The show is created and produced by Jeremy
Sherlick, Asher Ross, and me, Gabrielle Sierra.
Our sound designer is Markus Zakaria.
Robert McMahon is our Managing Editor, and
Doug Halsey is our Chief Digital Officer.
Our intern for this semester is Zoe Han.
Original music is composed by Ceiri Torjussen.
Additional research and extra help were provided
by Elena Tchainikova.
Special thanks go to Richard Haass and Jeff
Reinke.
For Why It Matters this is Gabrielle Sierra
signing off.
See you soon!